so scrolls are the bad guys and you're a
free a race of noble warriors heroes
noble warrior heroes when we meet Carol
in this film the Kree part of her is
your identity we see the cream on one
side of a war that they've been engaged
in for generations and there's force of
creased soldiers that Carol is a part of
called the Star Force there are really
incredible warriors the best at what
they do everything they do is food the
good of the cream is a real kind of
pride in that
I see Star Force fighting a war against
a shape-shifting enemy called us girls
the Kree see the scrolls as their
greatest threat they've got like a
chameleon ability but you know amped up
Carol knows the skulls have infiltrated
earth and it kind of craves the sense of
paranoia prove via not a scroll I was
grouping I'll do that this girls are
asked for something and part of the
mystery of the movie is Carol trying to
figure out what they're after and
getting it before they
before is just a beginning